[Music]
action
you can't oh oh i'm not supposed to read
the end no no no
oh she's old school dude yeah you
haven't been here
oh dude i'm always doing blank news
don't look because i have this thing
where's the last time you edited jk news
over over a year well over a year oh
that's why you don't know
it's been a minute more now because you
left the company like a year ago
yeah anyway sorry i yelled at you it was
my favorite
year it's been a year well
the thing we're gonna talk about today
though right now
is transformations
some like makeovers like before and
after and like how life
uh transforming it could be and this one
girl
in vietnamese in vietnam vietnam in
vietnam social media they're talking
about this chick
because she she revealed like photos her
before photos
and then like what she currently looks
like now so she's 21.
she said that at the age of 19 she
had surgery done and it was because
after breaking up with the boyfriend of
hers
she decided like you know what i gotta
change my looks because the boy my teddy
gotta go bigger
so it's like the modern day age of like
cutting off all my hair yeah well
for her so the boyfriend broke up with
her because of her looks
wait but he already knew he was gonna
date her like what the [ __ ]
i'm tired of these looks if you didn't
realize how ugly she was sorry i said it
wrong
she broke up with her boyfriend oh okay
okay because of her own looks wait what
this is what happened she went so she
was with her boyfriend in 11th grade
and she was only 17. oh these are kids
yeah yeah 17 at the time
and apparently they were very much in
love and that this guy would always tell
her how like
uh she didn't like she loved her for who
she was
not how she looked and all that stuff i
don't care how ugly you are man
but then her boyfriend would never
introduce her to any of his friends
oh red flags that's a huge sign right so
then
that means you just used for sex then
there was this one
party so a friend of theirs invited them
to
his birthday and then that's when um
that's when she realized that her
boyfriend
didn't invite i mean didn't introduce
her to his
friends and then throughout that whole
party she just
was she saw people pointing at her and
gossiping about how
such a handsome boy could be with such
an ugly girlfriend
damn oh that's what they were saying
yeah that's what they were saying at the
party
and then so her boyfriend ended up being
like very distant
throughout that whole party what a [ __ ]
and also again never introducing
to his friends you'll let her suck your
dick but you won't [ __ ]
introduce her what's wrong with you yeah
so then that was like really traumatic
and really humiliating and very
disappointing for this girl
so then that's when she decided to break
up with the boyfriend good and when she
broke up with him he didn't even care
which made her
feel even worse and it just ended up
being like a really traumatic experience
for her so she
ended up confining confiding in her mom
and telling her how like
she just hates her looks like she why'd
you give me [ __ ] up genetics [ __ ]
and so the surprisingly the mom was very
supportive
and actually made the appointment to the
doctor and was like i'll pay for your
surgery
i'm sorry was it her mom's idea she's
like
i'm sorry you're such an ugly [ __ ]
let's go get surgery baby
you can't get surgery on [ __ ] though oh
yeah that's true you can't
but yeah so the mom ended up paying for
her procedures
and so she ended up getting a nose a
nose job
cheek lip and chin fillers among other
things
i imagine she looks like a k-pop star
now yeah
she better be [ __ ] hot i gotta say as
soon as she graduated high school was
when she did like her
all her procedures and stuff and now she
says that she's really confident
she's when she's talking to people and
she's gained a new perspective
on life and she's actually grateful to
her ex-boyfriend
for that experience because it led her
to where she is now she's gonna get back
with them well the thing is that she
hasn't talked
she said she hasn't talked to her
ex-boyfriend like seen him
for the past four years but he does fall
he does follow her on social media and
likes pizzas
all of her photos of course and you know
she's gonna get back with him right no
she's not
she likes that he's staring at her
that's what she likes exactly
all right so steve knows and she posted
it on instagram
so here's the photos this is her after
the before damn the after yeah and this
is the before
he's princess she looks not that much of
a difference dude it just looks like
it just looks like she's a child and she
hasn't grown up yet there's another
before
that one was like the middle and i'm
sure she had the chanel
she had a nose job right she looked she
had the chanel
she looks regular like a regular asian
girl like she's not ugly that's after
that yeah after
yeah so she really the nose job is the
biggest difference yeah
nose job is the biggest yeah well her
cheeks too
her lips her cheek fillers her chin got
really pointy too yeah her chin
and her uh lips too did she have double
eyelids beforehand
um let me see i guess oh yeah her
eyelids too
she did do her eyeliner was that before
yeah this is beautiful
maybe that's mid hold on
maybe it's middle i mean nobody's that
by the way that you could tell that
yeah yeah skinny nose but the before
wasn't even bad yeah this is after
the before photo though is unfair nobody
looks good like this
i know right besides for that one weird
photo you said the other first two were
also before
no so the very first one with the red
dress is a after okay
and then there's three photos after that
red dress those are all before
yeah yeah yeah that were clear but it
wasn't the ones with the big bangs like
not only that one yeah yeah it was
pretty girl though like
in like current society if you don't
like the way you look you could just go
out and just change it
yeah you could transform it all yeah i
also think it's it's
probably not as big of a deal over there
because i feel like they get a lot of
influence from like
other parts of east asia like korea and
stuff yeah and plastic surgery in korea
is like no big deal
like people get it as like their 16th
birthday present to get the eyelid
surgery
yeah so it's like beverly hills is it
yeah yeah for like the 16th
everybody in la i didn't know this but
so many chicks get
work it's nuts yeah she looks really
cute though
even her like her before wasn't that
crazy no this is after
but even like her before like she was
just on normal girl
the only thing that's like really really
noticeable is her nose but we don't know
how fine her man is
true because if she's standing next to
her net man and he's like a k-pop star
it's like
okay she looks kind of off that's true
because then if he's like
yeah because then she could look cute
but then if she's standing next to like
a really really hot person it just makes
him look uglier
supposedly like what or you do ask the
question why is she with
him or like why like when even uh you
know you
in the if the couples don't match like
if
one just looks out of the league or
whatever you ask the question
why if it's a guy it's because oh he's
probably got money or something you make
that
excuse right but the same for the girl
you never go oh she's probably amazing
in bed oh i'm just kidding most people
people don't people don't i don't know
they they'll just judge right they'll
just talk [ __ ]
is what i'm saying what do you what are
your thoughts then when you see
people say they have shortcut thinking
that's what i say i say why
is she with him
[Applause]
because he's obviously ugly on the
inside girl easy applause lines
easy pants of him i don't have
pictures of him i don't know what do you
guys think when you see that
like an ugly guy or ugly which one
because i see that people
all got [ __ ] problems and it's hard
enough to keep a relationship together
so that's on them and good for them if
they could keep it going
but then a lot of people will make that
judgment they'll be like oh man like
he's too ugly for her he's probably rich
or or they'll be like oh she's so
ugly he could do so much better they
don't have like
just one word or one sentence
conclusions when i see things because i
know how complicated people are
because you just don't know how about
think about your younger self
oh i was [ __ ] dumb right yeah i think
that's mental that's when we can like
pinpoint our immediate reactions to his
questions
think of like so what then is okay is it
a hot girl a hot guy and a
hot guy hot guy with the ugly girl yeah
almost feels dumb
or or uh he's just using her to get the
other hot chicks or
he already has other chicks on the side
or this girl is rich and has what he
wants
my immediate yeah that's a lot of
thoughts yeah like 20 year old tiff
thinking when i would see a hot guy with
a like a
not as hot girl i would think man she
must
get bomb at his head blow job
i kind of think like that i i would i
would think does he look tired though
because maybe then yeah he's like yeah
he's like i'm so tired of all the heads
like a [ __ ] i would think that he has
really low self-esteem
see i i don't know when i see older guys
with young chicks i can't help but be
like ugh
yeah but how young are we talking about
and how old are you though
cause if you're 18 you'd be like yes no
like middle-aged dudes with like you
know 18 year olds or whatever
it's just um i see that as like
basically an inner child well at my age
now i'm like
disgusting right but then if when i was
like 16 i'm like lucky guy
lucky guy that's true yeah because from
my perspective
i always thought it was disgusting i
always thought
i honestly i think it's because i always
uh i always grew up seeing my dad with
little like younger girls like he would
pride himself in in getting them like
super young so i always thought that was
like
weird and gross and that's why i was for
my personal self when we had that
conversation a while back when we said
like how
what age gap are am i most comfortable
with and i'm like i can't
go younger that's [ __ ] gross to me
and i think it's because it's linked to
like
that with my dad but then also i can't
go like older than five years like
that's
nasty to me you can't date a guy that's
younger than you no
for me it's like when i see a
middle-aged guy in a corvette i'm like
oh it's the same exact feeling what if
you got it on the deal though
well i don't know that it looks pretty
new
it always looks pretty new i think for
me it depends on how they look
because i'm judgmental based on how ugly
they are
so if he's like old as hell but he's
ugly as [ __ ] and he's with this like
young hot girl then i'm like that's
disgusting
but if he's like let's say a guy that's
60 but he looks
fit and like like a freaking like he's
stylish
like he looks cool like an old rock star
and he's with a young girl then i'm like
oh dang dude he's still like youthful he
can get girls because in my mind i'm
thinking
she wants to be with him not she's
enslaved by him
the old ugly guy i'm thinking oh she
poor girl like she's
like she has to do this she has to be a
hooker
but then like when you see a a guy
that's kind of cool
grandpa or like someone who's
prestigious like an actor or whatever
it's like oh she like it's not so much
that he's a pride
it's not so much that she's a prize but
he's a prize so she's like winning him
but even then because we all see
dicaprio with like 19 year olds and [ __ ]
it's still [ __ ] weird to see
oh yeah yeah i don't think that's weird
i i think that not
because i think he's the prize he's the
catch right so then she
he could have any girl that he wants but
then like she
caught him so then it's not like um
she's this like it's a disgusting
situation for her
and then she's forced into it i don't
think that either
for me i think that he's taking
advantage of his
position to get like women that could be
his daughters
like that's just like a power thing well
plus they're always like models so they
have their own power too it's
it's it's not like they're it's not like
some like random
girl that needs him to like pay her
bills
yeah he's not like [ __ ] hot it's like
other celebrities or it might be a young
actress or whatever
it's always models almost all it's
almost yeah you're right you're right he
does have
a thing for models he just seems really
like
childish i guess to me yes there's
something there i don't know
because yeah i mean all his
relationships don't
last very long and it must be for a
reason we also thought about clooney too
and guess what clooney did what he did
he [ __ ] married pretty well
yeah he married like a u.n ambassador
and she's pretty hot
yeah i never thought it was creepy with
clooney either i don't know even though
the age difference was pretty big
i think this is the movies of him yeah
he's just like such a gentleman and such
so classy like seeing james bond with
someone
right
[Music]
[Music]
you